من الايقاف الى الاستجواب الامني ثم تحقيق
القضائي تتوالى الاحكام بالسجن على
المتورطين في التامر على امن الدوله
لانضاف اليها قرار قضائي بتجميد الاموال
والارصده للمتورطين فيها 17 مورطا الى حد
الان يقول لسان الدفاع عنهم ان القضيه
سياسيه ومفبركه في حين تؤكد بعض الجهات
الامنيه والجمعياتيه ان الجريمه مكتمله
الاركان
هنا عنا الدوله الخارج من الخارج الى
الداخل يعني واحنا الوقت الحاضر الشعب
الكل الشعب تونس الكل فاهم انتهاء شعب ما
عادش سادس عشر سنوات سوداء عديناهم عشر
سنوات اغتيالات 10 سنوات ضرب المؤسسه
رئاسه الجمهوريه
الى الامام ولا عوده الى الوراء ابدا
ونعمل عن قاده دوله التونسيه
يؤكد الرئيس سعيد انه لا مجال للعوده الى
الوراء ولا بد من انقاذ الدوله الا ان
صوتا اخر يرى انه يجب الفصل بين مسار
المحاسبه للمسؤولين عن العشريه السوداء
بكل ما رافقها كما انه من حق الدوله ان
تتتبع المجرمين مع كشف الحقيقه للراي
العام وضمان سلامه الاجراءات القانونيه
على الدوله وعلى المسؤولين الفرصه الدوله
هضم ان يخرج للراي العام وهذه معمول به في
العديد من المرات صارت في العالم ان
يوضحوا لابناء شعبنا ولراي العام الدولي
انه اليوم تم معطيات وثمه دلال تدين الناس
هديه باش ما نتركوش الباب والحجه لاي احد
انه اليوم يحاول يوظف الملف هذا ملف سياده
وملف امن وطني لصالح معناها موقف سياسي
ربما من مسار 25 جويليه وتؤكد المعطيات
الاوليه ان قائمه الاتهامات ستتوسع
مستقبلا مع تقدم التحقيقات في القضيه بعد
نحو اسبوعين من انطلاق حمله الاعتقالات ضد
متورطين في التامل على امن الدوله يصدر
القضاء التونسي
من الاحكام بالسجن ضد عدد من المتهمين وسط
توقعات بان تتسع رقعه الاعتقالات والاحكام
بالسجن مع تقدم التحقيقات في واحده من
اخطر القضايا وفق القانون التونسي وليد
عبد الله العربيه
تونس